bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus dans
le 19/20 sur france 3 une heure
d'informations voici tout de suite le
sommaire l'avenir de la grèce se joue en
ce moment à bruxelles et pour la
première fois les européens sont
optimistes quant à un accord
athènes a fait de nouvelles propositions
d'économies jugé raisonnable également
développé à 19h30 dans l'édition
nationale 20 mille patients en attente
de greffe il ya urgence à trouver de
nouveaux donneurs d'organes ce 22 juin
est la journée de sensibilisation pour
lutter contre les idées reçues
gros plan maintenant sur une idée
lumineuse on la doit à une petite start
up d'art et loire
l'entreprise energy astros a mis au
point un système qui permet de stocker
l'énergie solaire une innovation
distingué parmi eux 200 autres projets à
l'occasion d'un concours organisé par
edf reportage à châteaudun de meriem
métaoui et dit le pape
ce cylindre n'a l'air de rien pourtant
il s'agit d'un système de stockage
d'énergie révolutionnaire ce produit là
et quand même déjà très innovant il a
été récompensé l'an dernier au concours
mondial d'innovation
c'est un volant de stockage d'énergie
solaire en acier donc l'acier c'est la
technologie on va dire actuelle que
beaucoup de gens utilisent mais qui a un
gros défaut on va dire c'est que elle
est chère à l'achat
du coup les chercheurs d'énergie ce trou
en l'augmentera vaille et sur toutes
sortes de matériaux pour finalement
arriver au béton dix fois moins cher que
l'acier le béton est un matériau
finalement je ne vais pas dire
écologique ce serait exagéré parce que
la fabrication de béton consomment
beaucoup quand même deux
il faut aussi mais ça évidemment en
train de changer on essaye de remplacer
les énergies fossiles par des énergies
renouvelables mais dans tous les cas le
béton va consommer peu d'énergie et
mettre peu de carbone au départ et
ensuite un volant en béton là où c'est
intéressant c'est qui va durer très
longtemps
grâce à cette toute nouvelle technologie
moins cher et moins polluantes que les
batteries chacun pourra créer sa propre
énergie de façon indépendante
les premiers marchés que nous visons
sont quand même des gros marchés
industriels pour mettre des parcs
solaires dans les zones très
ensoleillées mais effectivement le
marché final c'est d'avoir du stockage
partout pour conserver toutes les
énergies produites et tous les bâtiments
du futur auront des panneaux solaires
sur le toit
donc ça a du sens de mettre le stockage
sur place grâce à cette maquette on
comprend comment le système fonctionne
le principe du vote volant de stockage
solaire est simple emmagasiner l'énergie
pour pouvoir la restituer quand un nuage
passe ou quand il fait nuit
les parcs photovoltaïques pourrait ainsi
devenir de véritables centrales
électriques l'information continue à
suivre vos éditions locales entourent
année dans le berry partout ailleurs on
se retrouve juste après la météo pour
cette hausse entre ath au site